[музика]
Ярослава За
відпущення і дав йому владу суд творити
бо він є син
[музика]
людський
ми згадуємо його як молоду дуже чисту
справжню з високими моральними якостями
людини з прекрасним почуттям гумору а
Повірте що ми будемо робити все для того
щоби як нейшвидше ті принципи за які
боровся
мирак і із ворогом і в
тилу вони були реалізовані це Україна
демократична це Україна член є се Ната -
це Україна де шанують військового світла
пам'ять золотий хлопчику воїни Прекрасна
людина І знаєте Наш будинок зараз він
руйнується тому що ідуть найкращі ті хто
мали будувати мали
будувати майбутню Україну тому дуже
важливо щоб ми не зрадили їх принципи їх
пам'ять і і це наше завдання вічна
пам'ять тобі сьогодні на службі Божій
Сергій сказав дуже важливі важливі слова
що Мирослава знали всі бо він боровся за
людей він бажав робити життя людей
кращими ми ми горді бути разом в цій
боротьбі і всі хто зараз не на фронті
мають один священний обов'язок зробити
так щоби наша армія була міцною щоб вона
не знала ні в чому недостачі щоби
кожного героя шанували і щоби ця міцна
сильна армія помстилася за за кожного
хто вернувся додому на щиті Слава
Україні Героям
слава він був тим хто закладав перші
камушки Азова перші перші кроки потім
він прийшов сюди робити повернувся
додому
робити зміни перетворювати державу на
справжню європейську країну а потім він
повернувся до
нас на жаль не всі герої повертаються до
мо щитом деякі
житі але Кожний з нас знає ціну Перемоги
Кожний з нас знає що перемога так просто
не
[музика]
дається